we've looked at using calculus to find
stationary points and we know the most
interesting or useful kinds of
stationary points are usually ones where
there are turning points turning points
of course fall into two categories where
you're turning and you're concave down
which means your maximum or your turning
in you're concave up which means you're
a minimum okay so we looked in abstract
at finding the maximum value of a
function
some magical weird function that you
have no idea what it refers to but now
we want to actually apply this to
specific problems where you've got
actual quantities that our X's and Y's
and SS and T's that they actually refer
to so this is a pretty classic example
okay you've got a rectangle with a given
length they just provide a pronumeral
for you though it's worth mentioning if
they don't provide a pronumeral for you
sometimes you've got to define it
yourself they tell you it's got a
constant area of 36 square centimeters a
constant area of 36 square centimeters
which kind of clears you in to the fact
that the other thing that's there the
other quantity is not constant it can
vary it can change okay and the question
is very simple what's the smallest
perimeter what's the minimum primitive
we can find for this rectangle now I've
got four steps for you and we're gonna
work through each one
they each require a bit of thought but
if you've got the four steps down I
think you'll be you'll be all right the
four step step four and if you can think
of a better acronym than I can then go
for it model look for restrictions use
calculus and then actually answer the
question okay create a model of the
situation which is generally going to be
some kind of equation we can
differentiate once you created that
model look carefully and see whether
there are any restrictions that apply to
the model the reason why you drew that
straight away is because once you get on
the calculus train you get so like into
the pattern that you forget that there
are restrictions that apply you just
kind of think of them as letters that
move around and it's a classic problem
that people that students make an error
that they forget their restrictions they
get answers out of the calculus and
don't actually think about what they
mean then you do your differentiating
find your Max or being as relevant and
once you find that go back to the
question and have a look at what the
questions actually asking
make sure you answer it okay model
restrictions calculus answer let's have
a go now to create the model I want to
use all the information that's been
provided to be in the question there's a
rectangle with length x so the first
thing we're going to do not that you
have to do this but I don't know why you
would it is I'm going to draw the thing
here is my rectangle okay now if you've
got a rectangle and it has length X then
its width is going to be based on its
area right because you also know its
area the area of a rectangle of course
is most times width so just look at that
can you tell me what the width of this
rectangle should be just remember I
should multiply these together yeah so
if I multiply these together to get 36
then it stays the reason that this is 36
on X does that make sense
multiple together just to check yes
you're going to get 36 fine so I've got
the dimensions of my rectangle okay this
is part of my model by the way I'm just
creating it as I go
now the area is what I use to find these
dimensions here but what I'm actually
trying to get toward is this perimeter
right I'm trying to minimize perimeter
which means I need the perimeter as a
function of for the variables that I've
got right so I'm going to write P for
perimeter equals and look I just have to
add all these things up right so you can
see it's going to be 2x plus when you
add 36 or next to 36 or X you're gonna
get 72 on X yeah okay how are you going
so far that make sense that wasn't too
arduous right I probably should have
said let the perimeter be P but you guys
get what I'm doing here okay so I've
pretty much created my model now write
this this entire thing that I've written
constitution my model it demonstrates
what's going on here and the lab is
you'll work with what's going on so
after I create my model what's my next
step
look for restrictions okay so X which is
the variable it can't just be anything
you like right
there are restrictions that are implied
in the question what anyone like to
suggest some to me
X has to be greater than zero X is alike
right so therefore the length has to be
positive so I can say right over here
that X has to be greater than zero
connects be equal to zero not if you
wanted a rectangle with actual area
right
is there an upper boundary like X can't
be any bigger than this
if X don't really really be like say a
hundred centimeters or so that it's
super long thing could you still create
a rectangle with the appropriate width
to give it the area that it's supposed
to have you could write it would be
really long it would just be very very
thin right so I can keep on doing that
infinitely I can't do that with an
actual piece of paper and a rectangle
but I can do that mathematically right
so therefore there's no up around around
this that's the only restriction so
models ready restrictions done now go
start doing calculus I'm working for a
minimum so what am I going to do to this
expression here I'm going to go to the
first derivative right I've said before
that I don't like though you know the y
dash notation because it sort of
eliminates what's going on here there's
not this is not a function of Y it's
it's capital P so I'm gonna write D P on
D X right so this is where this notation
starts to come into its own because it
tells you exactly what you're
differentiating and what you're
differentiating with respect to okay you
can differentiate probably what am I
going to get this is going to give me
two and then this is actually 72 X to
the negative one so the negative will
come out the front I multiply by that
and then the power reduces by one which
is X to the negative two so that's
actually down here is that okay you're
all right with that okay fantastic
so this is the derivative what do I do
with it why did I bother differentiating
I need to find the minima so the minimum
is most likely to occur at a stationary
point right it's worth mentioning all
that stuff we said last time about
endpoints or what have you
also have to be considered however in
this square in this case this actual
question I know the endpoints are
irrelevant can anyone tell me why how
we'll look carefully the question
what are the end points now this is a
bit weird it's been a trick question
because um there are in fact their end
points can you see why think about it
think about like what's the lowest that
X can be think of a number and you can't
actually think of a number right because
if i said i 0 point 1 is that lowest
well you can have it 0.01 if you want or
0.001 you keep on getting smaller and
smaller as well you of course we
establish before you can't actually get
to 0 so that's not an endpoint and we
also explain you can't go any further in
that direction also you can go as far as
you like in that direction there's no
end point over that end so it doesn't
actually have end points but often this
is where the end points come from that
might be worth writing down this is
where end points are from because you
only get them where there's some kind of
domain restriction right so all of that
just to say re-emphasize yes I'm looking
for my stationary points